what's going on guys today we're
examining which characters from maya
academia
would be best suited to inherit the nine
titan shifters
in attack on titan for those of you not
familiar with the concept of a titan
shifter
they're basically people who can
transform and switch between being a
human or a titan
at will only nine titan shifters exist
and their power can be passed down from
one person to another
so it's a bit like one for all just way
more gruesome
each titan shifter has its own unique
ability and a person can inherit a titan
shifter at
any age with many characters in attack
on titan receiving their titans before
they were even teenagers
before we begin don't forget to sub for
more crossover videos like this
and also a special shout out to my
patreon supporters and youtube members
you guys helped make this possible and i
really appreciate it but without further
ado
let's get into the video okay so to
start off with an easy one
the first titan we're going to select a
character for is the armored titan
the armored titan's most notable feature
is its incredible durability
which is thanks to these hardened plates
all over its body this armor is good for
defense and attack
as in the anime we saw how it survived a
bombardment
that probably would have killed other
titans and it's also able to hold its
own when it comes to a fight
most of the time at least if my hero
characters were in this universe
this titan would be inherited by
kiroshima because he's the best at
knowing when to use hardening
to protect himself or to attack his
personality is also suited to the
armored titan
because he has the strength of character
to stand up even when he's getting
absolutely battered
additionally i see similarities between
kiroshima and this titan
because when the armor titan was
originally shown for the first time
it looked like an unstoppable killing
machine but we eventually saw that under
the right circumstances
it could be broken to me this was
reminiscent of when we first saw
kiroshima's unbreakable form only for it
to be surprisingly broken
sooner than we thought next up we have
the attack titan
which is the perfect shifter for a main
character not only does it have
incredible strength
but over the years whoever has had this
titan has never obeyed others
people who have the attack titan fight
for what they believe is right
and they keep moving forward even when
the law is against them
for all those reasons izuka midoriya
would definitely get the attack titan
because time and time again he does what
he believes is right
even when literally everyone tries to
convince him otherwise
during the post-credits scene for season
4 of my hero academia we saw that deku
is able to see the memories of
previous inheritors of one for all the
attack titan is also quite talented when
it comes to seeing the memories of other
people who've had it
so this is another quality that makes
them similar midoriya is also quite
athletic
and he knows how to properly use super
strength so all in all
him having the attack titan would be a
perfect match
the third titan on this list is one that
will appear in the final season of
attack on titan
but if you don't know what it does then
i'd recommend you pause the video
and skip to the time stamp on screen for
the rest of you
the warhammer titan is one of the most
unique titan shifters
as it's able to create weapons and other
structures by hardening titan flesh
examples of its creations include a
hammer and this massive pillar
this titan is also special in that it
has been held by one family for
generations
and that family is very wealthy and
highly regarded
in my hero academia momo's quirk allows
her to create anything she wants
ranging from weapons to other useful
devices
also she is one of the most high status
students in all of ua
with her family having an incredible
amount of wealth as evidenced by this
massive mansion it seems that at the
very least if she was born in the attack
on titan universe
then she would fulfill the criteria to
be the next warhammer titan
as she comes from a wealthy family and
is able to create things very well as
we've seen
so yeah she would inherit the warhammer
titan moving over to the draw titan now
i say that this is the swiftest titan
around and it has a set of jaws
that can bite through virtually anything
this titan would be perfect for baka go
and not just because he looks like this
when he's angry bakugo's movements in
battle are perhaps the best of anyone in
class 1a
i mean they were so good that deku
decided to copy them so clearly you know
he's doing something right
another thing to mention is probably the
draw titan sharp clause
i mean i could definitely see bakago
putting those to use so if he was in
this universe
then he would be a worthy draw titan
the founding titan is the next one we're
going to choose a candidate for
and this all-powerful titan would be
inherited by all for one
the founding titan is basically
invincible when used at its full
potential
i mean it can forcefully control other
titans at will and make them do what it
wants
which is reminiscent of how afo would
use force quirk activation
the founder can also manipulate the
memories of other people
to make them forget certain events and
it can change the composition
of other people's bodies all for one has
also consistently messed around with
other people's bodies
throughout his experiments with dr ujuko
to create the nomu
when the founding titan is at its full
power it's nearly unstoppable
and afo himself is the same think about
it it took
eight generations of one for all users
before someone was finally able to beat
all for one
so it just shows you that he's on
another level compared to all the other
characters
if he was in attack on titan then the
founder would be the only titan worthy
of someone like him moving on to the
female titan
as the name suggests it has to be a girl
who inherits this one
and i think this would go to himiko toga
the female titan is ruthless
agile and it has a spoilery ability that
i'll get to later
all those qualities make toga the ideal
candidate because she's shown her
agility and athleticism
not to mention her ruthlessness the
possessor of this titan should also be
good at going undercover
and this is something that we've seen
toga do on many an occasion whether it
was
you know during the provisional license
exam or during the overhaul arc
you know infiltration is basically what
she does now
both toga and the female titan have
special abilities
that haven't been mentioned in the anime
for both my hero
and attack on titan so skip to the time
stamp if you don't want to know these
major spoilers
it was revealed in the attack on titan
manga that the female titan is
especially good
at replicating the abilities of other
titans if it consumes a part of them
this is similar to toga's new ability
which she discovered during the myvlan
academia arc
and this is where she can mimic the
quirk of someone she loves
if she consumes their blood what this
means
is that both the female titan and toga
can copy the powers of someone else
through consumption so the parallels are
just way too clear for her
not to be this titan shifter the seventh
titan on this list
is the beast titan and i consider it to
be one of my personal favorites
while the beast titan may look like a
giant disproportionately sized monkey
the intro for season 3 showed us that
not all beast titans have to take this
form
rather the appearance of a beast titan
will be dictated by
you know it's not it's unclear but what
we saw was that zeke used to be a fan of
monkeys
and that's what he became when he was a
titan so in theory there could be any
type of animal as a beast titan
depending on what that person likes i
guess that's what it is
i originally considered that koda might
get the beast titan due to his love of
animals
but ultimately there was someone who was
way better suited to getting this titan
tamaki amajiki would be the one to get
the beast titan
because he knows best how to use animal
characteristics in battle
whether tamaki was turned into a cow
titan or a squid titan or a chicken
titan
or anything else i mean he would be the
best person to know how to use it
properly
although he may be timid and quite
nervous at times at the end of the day
he is one of the top three students at
ua
so if he was in the attack on titan
universe then he would definitely be one
of the top candidates to inherit the
beast titan and uh yeah i'm sure he
would get it in the end
the colossal titan is up next and this
was actually the first titan shifter we
ever saw in the series
standing over 60 meters tall it's been
described as a god of destruction
and is easily capable of wiping out
towns or cities
if used correctly unlike other titans
the colossal can choose to create a
massive explosion upon transforming
which has an incredible power its size
also means that it can crush
large areas just by walking forwards and
as we saw in seasons 2 and 3
the user of the colossal can burn people
up with its steam
or just blow them away there were a few
people i had in mind to inherit this
titan
mainly those with gigantification quirks
like mount lady or gigantomachia
however due to developments in the my
hero manga which i won't go into
i feel that shigeru raki is the
embodiment of what this titan represents
this colossal titan is only good for
destruction like
what else can it do besides destroying
things i can't think of a good reason
obviously you have the wall titans which
are similar but not identical
um so when we're talking about the real
colossal titan
yeah it's only good for destroying
things and so shigeraki would have to
inherit it because
he is destruction personified and all he
wants to do is destroy things
finally the last of the nine titans is
the cart titan
which is a handy shifter but uh
definitely the least intimidating of the
nine
the kart titan walks on four legs and is
able to stay in titan form for a very
long time
it can be used to carry supplies or as
we saw in season 4
it can have weapons planted on top of it
my decision on who would get this titan
was more of a gut feeling
and the person i chose was mineta i just
feel like if there was someone
who would walk around on all fours and
carry things for other people
minetta would probably be the one to do
it if he thought he'd get something out
of it
that being said it's guaranteed that he
would also complain a lot
whilst doing so and there you have it
guys that was my list on which micro
academia characters
would inherit the nine titans hit that
like button if you like this video
and let me know your selections down
below until the next one
peace out